have you ever bought something that you
were like this is amazing and when you
go to your aunt you're like you got to
try these shoes on the thing that will
fix your tone is actually believing in
the product we see this with sales teams
and I can tell you I can fix a sales
team rather than training them on
drilling obstacle overcomes and things
like that by simply saying what's
happened in the last seven days 14 days
30 days that made you believe in this
class and solving for that and sometimes
there's a legitimate problem with a
product or a service and it's like we're
on it and then we start giving them
updates every day of the things that
we're doing to solve the problem that
they brought up we're getting to the
heart of it if you don't believe in it
you shouldn't sell